[музика]
вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі Європи
і телекомпанії Deutsche Welle Уявіть
собі що вас позбавили ваших прав багато
того що досі мало для вас значенні
сприймалося як належне раптом скінчилося
це трапилось із багатьма жінками в
Афганістані відколи італіби перейшли до
влади рік тому жінкам доводиться жити за
їхніми правилами багатьом більше не
дозволяють ходити до школи університету
на роботу чи на спортивні змагання і
виходити з дому вони можуть лише з
дозволу чоловіка
сахар вчасно втекла від талібану до
Венеції воно не хотіла відмовлятися від
свого самостійного життя вже рік Вона
живе в еміграції в Італії налагоджуючи
своє життя але тепер сахар боїться за
свою безпеку
правий екстремістська Джорджа Мелані має
чудові шанси отримати більшість на
майбутніх парламентських виборах Це не
дуже добре новина для біженців вважає
сахар Віталій вона користується захистом
толерантністю Та свободою всім чого
позбавили жінок на її батьківщині
коли сахар сумує або в розпачі коли
отримає погані новини з Афганістану вона
приходить сюди
широкий світ перед очима
із її батьківщини доходять лише погані
новини
А зараз вона працює в ресторані свого
брата досвід сходу
ресторан до якого хамед наймає на роботу
лише біженців і він дає їм шанс
потрапити до Венеції як от своїй сестрі
сахар
те що я працюю допомогло мені трохи
вийти з депресії тут я пригадую як
працювала у своєму власному ресторані в
кабулі я збудувала там ресторан
мені принаймні це вдалося
та відкрито його Я вже не змогла
але як щодо всіх тих дівчат та жінок
Афганістані чиї бажання та надії не
можуть зараз здійснитися
таке відчуття що твоє тіло живе душа
мертва
якщо вмирає твій дух і твої бажання та
насправді теж вже мертва
але в неї є нова мета а вона хоче стати
в Італії шеф-кухаркою
у Венеції вона вже зв'язалась із
кількома шеф-кухарями відповідь була
позитивною чи заслужила я все це запитаю
вона себе постійно коли слухає новини із
кабула
дівчина якій ми телефонуємо з міркувань
безпеки не хоче щоб називали її ім'я
Вона живе в кабулі із 13-ма сестрами
через рік я відчуваю що більше не існує
мені заборонено вчитися
мені заборонено самостійно обирати собі
одяг
ми почуваємося наче пташки що не можуть
літати і зачинені у клітці
тепер вони виходять на вулицю одягнені в
бурку і то рідко тому що таліби кажуть
що жінки повинні виходити з дому лише з
поважної причини ти сама чи може твої
сестри виходили коли-небудь на вулицю
брали участь у протестах жінок проти
талібана щоб захистити свої права
ми хотіли але коли побачили що таліби
роблять із демонстранками шмагають їх і
карають батько заборонив нам це робити
іноді сахар ледь може дихати розповідає
вона нам тоді вона виходить і безцільно
гуляє вулицями Венеції останнім часом
люди все частіше говорять про те що
праві партії можуть перемогти на виборах
наприкінці вересня тоді Джорджія меллоні
може стати прем'єр-міністром сахар це
дуже хвилює Можливо тоді їй доведеться
залишити Італію її брат хамед
намагається позбавити її цього страху
як виглядає політика мелоні стосовно
мігрантів
отже вона лідер правої партії в Італії
і вона проти біженців і мігрантів
але не проти українців з ними в неї
проблем немає
але з нами в неї можуть бути проблеми чи
ні
не безпосередньо з нами але це
стосується її міжнародної політики вона
принципова у питаннях біженців та
мігрантів так
але потім він вселяє в сахар упевненість
але знаєш сахар Зараз ти живеш там де
Якби ти захотіла навіть сама змогла б
зайняти місце такої як Мелені якщо вона
стане прем'єр-міністром
в Афганістані під владою талібану це
більше неможливо
і потім вони роблять те що більше
неможливо в Афганістані а вони
відчувають свободу
Зараз ми познайомимо вас із двома
фінанами пекою та партії пурманено
обидва живуть на кордоні з Росією
говорить з російською і лише добрі слова
про сусідів на іншому боці але відтоді
як Путін наказав розпочати загарницьку
війну проти України жителі невеликого
прикордонного містечка в'ярціля що на
півночі Фінляндії сперечаються щодо
політики шок від війни тут великий але
щодо того хто Лиходій думки дуже
розходяться
ідилія посеред фінської тайги
тут пролягає кордон із сусідньої Росією
протяжністю 1300 км
десятиліттями тут панував спокій
але відтоді як Росія вторглася в Україну
все змінилося кажуть фіни перті пурмонен
і пека-кунес
обидва вважають що мир під загрозою і
сперечаються про те хто несе за це
відповідальність
Я не довіряю росіянам Європа мала
продемонструвати єдність набагато раніше
зараз мені шкода український народ
поселяючи зброю в Україну ми атакуємо
самих росіян для росіян ми тепер ворог
два місяці тому партія і його дружина
придбали тут у вівці невеликі готель
І хоча відтоді гості приїжджають але їх
замало
перті фурманен сумує за російськими
гостями які приїжджали влітку йому
подобається люди по той бік кордону
він сам часто бував у Росії у справах і
приватно і вважає що в наявній ситуації
винна не лише Москва ми боїмося тому що
зовнішня політика Фінляндії стає все
більше агресивною щодо сходу це Мене
хвилює
залишається тільки сподіваюся що ми
вціліємо і що російські ракети просто
пролетять На дамах що їх коли-небудь
випустять
п какунас також говорить російською Але
на відміну від свого сусіда він більше
не хоче щоб росіяни приїжджали до вівці
Він каже що раніше щодня виглядав тут
чотирилапих хижаків
Сьогодні його хвилюють двоногі
від чого знаку до державного кордону
всього 150 метрів
Ми почуваємось так і ми постійно стоїмо
навпроти Великого Хижака
не боїмося але мусимо щодня стежити за
цим хижаком
Поки що все мирно спека кунас із
нетерпінням чекає на традиційне щорічно
шоу ретро автомобілів У сусідньому місті
і ломанці
він був пожежником Тому пенсіонер
особливо пишається пожежним автомобілем
і з 1960-х років у той час між сходом і
заходом тривала Так звана холодна війна
фінська Карелія завжди була прикордонним
регіоном сьогодні тут проходить кордон
ЄС Шенгенської зони
незабаром найдовший суцільний кордон
НАТО із Росією але багатьох тут цікавить
питання як це вплине на стосунки із
сусідами
чи можуть російські туристи і надалі
безперешкодно в'їжджати в країну
спочатку року росіяни подали документи
на отримання майже 60 тисяч фінських
військ більшість хотіли летіти звідси
далі
зараз багато країн ЄС хочуть закрити ці
ворота до Західної Європи
Одні кажуть що росіяни не можуть
відпочивати на заході в той час коли
вони ведуть війну у центрі Європи
інші ж відповідають чому б і ні не можна
звинувачувати у війні всіх росіян
сперечаються про це навіть на шоу ретро
автомобілів веломанці
дуже добре коли звичайні люди розуміють
яка в них влада
загалом люди схожі на свій уряд
одна держава напала на іншу суверенну
державу тому правильно обмежувати
кількість росіян і використовувати це як
санкційний захід Я сподіваюсь що так
вийде покращити ситуацію
На мою думку кордон закривати не варто
коли до нас приїжджають росіяни Вони
отримують через нас інший погляд на світ
тому що суспільство в якому вони там
живуть закрите і зараз вони отримують
лише односторонню інформацію
у Фінляндії зменшення кількості
російських туристів відчувається вже
давно
я сподіваюся що здоровий глузд переможе
і що ми знайдемо впливових державних
діячів які разом зможуть розв’язати це
питання
важливіше щоб ми могли жити в мирі дуже
близько до кордону і не задумуватися над
тим що йде з того боку з невідомого
сходу
Утім колись добросусідські стосунки між
фінанами та росіянами вже зараз і
зіпсовані на роки
тут вздовж їхнього кордону протяжністю
понад тисячу кілометрів
чи скоро в нас гасне світло багато країн
Європи готується до енергодефіциту
холодну пору року це стосується і
Франції приблизно дві третини своєї
електроенергії країни виробляє за
допомогою атомної енергетики І власне
тому досить незалежний від російського
газу однак через те що половина
французьких атомних електростанцій зараз
не працює з технічних причин енергії
бракуєць Вітрова енергетика ще не
розбудована тож Усе більше французів
вимушені економити електроенергію вже
зараз
коли в Парижі настає ніч світло
вимикається
молоді активісти показують приклад
[музика]
Звісно що це символічно але послання
зрозуміло кожен може робити щось для
економії енергії
при цьому електроенергія тут ніколи не
була проблемою атомний Рай Франції
атомна електроенергія в шенон є однією
із найстаріших її запустили ще в 1963
році і з того часу тут відбулася низка
аварій проте термін її експлуатації які
всіх інших французьких атомних
електростанцій було продовжено на 10
років у Франції частка атомної
енергетики становить 70%.»
настрій тут явно про атомний адже
електростанція найбільший роботодавець у
місті розповідає нам Кухарка
і завжди була Мої батьки мої дідусі і
бабусі допомагали їй будувати Мій рідний
батько брав участь у будівництві
центрального вузла атомної станції це
наша спільна спадщина
чи не боїться вона всіх ризиків
Ні я взагалі не боюся
у виробника паркету шенде-франс теж
нічого не працює без атомної
електроенергії електроенергію для
виробництва завод повністю отримує із
сусідньої атомної електростанції перед
усім для сушіння деревини
з огляду на енергетичну кризу та Стрілка
зростання цін комерційний директор більш
ніж задоволений атомною енергетикою яку
субсидує Держава
це наше опалення воно працює на гарячій
воді з АЕС
з економічної точки зору без ядерної
енергетики ми попустилися на коліна
через вартість енергії що й далі зростає
Він головний атомний лобіст для
президента макрона атомна енергетика це
майбутнє але фактично половина
французьких атомних електростанцій зараз
не працює А ще держава штучно підтримує
низькі ціни на енергоносії за допомогою
мільярдних субсидій однак макрон точно
знає що далі йому це не вдасться кризове
засідання в єлисейському палаці слід
виробити національний план реагування на
надзвичайні ситуації
ми зробили ставку виключно на атом
навіть не наближаючись до розбудови
відновлювальних джерел енергії Франція
Єдина країна в Європі яка не досягла
своїх цілей щодо розбудови на 2020 рік
це мають надолужити
усе назирі у британі будується найбільше
офшорний парк Франції вартістю 2
мільярди євро
глибоко в морі встановлять 80 вітрових
турбін і це лише початок планується ще
якщо вітрові турбіни запрацюють то
зможуть забезпечувати енергію 700 тисяч
людей це як населення Франкфурта
однак у Гавані це викликає захоплення не
в усіх то мав 18 років поспіль виїжджає
на своєму катері ловити крабів хоча
вітрові турбіни знаходяться не в районі
його риболовлі Він усе одно стурбований
Вони сказали не хвилюйся і бла бла
але в ситуацію видно відразу коли
приходиш на пляж це вже трохи шокує
енергія вітру та екологічно чистий
водень є для Франції майбутніми
джерелами енергії але проблеми неможливо
вирішити у короткостроковій перспективі
і атомну енергетику вони тут ще довго не
замінять
це є футзальний м'яч
так футзал - це різновид футбол в який
грають у приміщенні
дізнайся Я не знав що такий відомий
футболісти як Пеле чи Роналду перш ніж
стати футбольним легендами грали в
футзал
напевно на таку кар'єру сподівається
також і ці юнаки з Чехії серед них
багато членів ромської етнічної меншини
їм особливо важко але на півночі Чехії
вусі над набою дехто дає їм шанс
вести м'яч пританцьовувати обводити
футзал - це швидка футбольна гра на
вузькому просторі з невеликою командою і
хлопці Лукаша пулко досить добре вміють
це робити Давай швидше давай
Марсель пас краще Так ось так це має
виглядати Саме так
але важливішою каже Лукаш є школа у
першу чергу тому що багато юнаків
належить до ромської меншини Тож
приготуватись до перевірки табеля
блок краще якби маленький Міша прийшов
не лише із посередніми оцінками
Я повинен тобі сказати що тобі
доведеться зробити перерву до кінця
вересня
ти не ходитимеш з нами ні на тренування
ні на ігри
Міша помітно вражений але він не
відступає Він приймає своє покарання
то залишається щоб дивитися як
тренуються інші Тому що футбол це все що
вони мають тут у крашняку як вони
називають свій район
район панельних будинків знаходиться за
два кілометри від центру міста Усті
колишній Шахтарські регіон сьогодні все
ще структурно слабкий тут Найвищий
рівень безробіття в Чехії
Лукаш оператор екскаватора і працює у
цивільному секторі йому та його сім'ї це
вдалося
це фірма мого брата він її заснував він
наш шеф
Я працюю на нього разом і ще з одним
братом Пеппою
можна сказати що це сімейний бізнес
роботу знаходиться Той хто справді хоче
каже Лукаш саме Таке відношення робить
його взірцем для молоді
все почалося 8 років тому він стояв на
своєму балконі один бразильський друг
футболіст щойно привіз йому цілий
комплект футболок із монгового Бразилія
саме В ту неділю я спостерігав як унизу
на площі грають діти
це була доля
я спустився і подарував йому футболки
так виник монго наш клуб
відтоді він тренує хлопців і забирає їх
із вулиці для них це почесно грати за
мангагуа
Я думаю що ми на правильному шляху але
багато дітей тут усе ще мають проблеми
алкоголь наркотики та азартні ігри
тим часом клуби монгагуа є вже у восьми
інших чеських містах історія успіху а в
регіоні Усті Лукаша через онлайн
голосування обрали особистістю 2021 року
я перший Ром Який отримав цю нагороду
А ще найбільше голосів серед усіх
номінантів
він був одним із перших членів монгагуа
сьогодні Денні грає за команду Рапід
Усті у чеській футзальній Лізі клуб
підписав з ним первинний контракт день
на шляху до професіоналізму
багато ромських хлопців і дівчат
невпевнені в собі вони кажуть я її
страшніка і залишаюся таким як іншим
ходжу на роботу і живу тут і мені цього
достатньо вони задовольняються малим але
це не життя ми повинні жити своїми
мріями
так виглядала площа ще за часів Дені з
приблизно 20 спортивних майданчиків
району відремонтовано лише один
але Лукаш не хоче просто скаржитися
мало що робиться
багато людей говорять але нічого не
роблять
Я бачу це щодня
і мені дуже шкода особливо хлопців
ми наштовхуємося на нерозуміння громадян
що живуть у районі панельних будинків
біля цього спортивного майданчика
Діти завжди користувалися ним але зараз
частина громадян не хоче модернізації
майданчика вони бояться що там
збиратимуться молодь щоб просто зависати
а не займатися спортом
Лукаша пулко це не бентежить
адже вирішальним є те щоб хлопці
продовжували грати на футзальному полі
чи поза ним
костюм пошитий на замовлення найтонша
круче на нитка на грудна хусточка це
класичний комплект одягу англійського
джентельмена але його зовнішній вигляд
постраждав від пандемії багато людей
охоче перейшли в домашніх офісах на
зручні спортивні штани
для лондонських чоловічих гравців
зокрема Джеймса сліттера це стало шоком
Він втратив усі замовлення і його
тривожило питання чи не гулятиме
незабаром свійська людина лондонським
Сіті у тонкому шовку замість благородної
тканини ні проте на вулицях може стати
трошки яскравіше
а Лондон савіл роул більше традицій У
чоловічому одязі бути не може Джеймс
літер відкрив свою крамницю о 14 років
тому раніше він був банкіром тепер
продає костюми пошиті на замовлення та
офісний одяг бізнес ішов добре проте до
пандемії
наш бізнес із пошиття одягу різко
обвалився щонайменше на 80%, Але після
закінчення локдауну це фантастика У
більшості людей змінилася фігура або
вони стали фанатами фітнесу або ж
влаштували собі за великий Комфорт
замовляли багато їжі яку їли вдома бо
більше нічого було робити
локдаун як прискорювач моди нові форми
тіла означають що потрібен новий одяг
Отже інсас літера стільки роботи як
ніколи до цього
Після місяців років у домашньому офісі
чоловіки хочуть чогось нового
щоб одяг не обмежував їх або в
комфортнішим
[музика]
якщо я одягаю вранці темний костюм то це
просто
але якщо я вибираю піджак то мені
потрібно підібрати до нього штани туфлі
треба більше задумуватися це означає
більше замовлень для кравця
але може бути яскравіше наприклад халати
з оксамиту та шовку це неперевершено
Маркес Девіс молодий підприємець може
собі дозволити одягнути щось подібне на
ділову зустріч
[музика]
під час
за допомогою всіх деталей я можу
висловити свою особистість
все що сорочки і краватка а зверху
пальто воно додає мені якоїсь
впевненості
[музика]
хоча носити мерехтливі халати
наважуються Сьогодні лише особливо
сміливі але традиційні темні костюми
можна побачити в центрі Лондона справді
рідко цього літа англійській gentleman
віддає перевагу розкутості
це пов'язано з прагненням до свободи так
говорить мовний блогер Алекс цвєткович
із Надією що карантин уже позаду
[музика]
діловий костюм переживає кризу
Утім водночас відбувається щось
неймовірне якщо чоловікам більше не
потрібно носити костюм Як уніформу то
Вони можуть використовувати його для
розвитку своєї особистості ми
спостерігаємо це у Лондоні останні
кілька років
костюм більше не уніформа а аксесуар
стилю життя
той хто обирає сьогодні костюм робить це
свідомо
зокрема захарі фройд
[музика]
На своє весілля він цілком традиційно
замовляє смокінг
інших гостей також просили пройти у
смокінг
тому людям хочеться задуматись над своїм
зовнішнім виглядом
тож Джеймсон слітер не доводиться
хвилюватись ще матиме його майстерність
попит у майбутньому
костюм ніколи не зникне завжди будуть
співбесіди завжди будуть весілля і
англійський Джентльмен ніколи не може
бути одягнутим занадто гарно якщо на
коктейльній вечірці Я єдиний у краватці
то я просто її зніму до того ж бути
найкраще одягнутим чоловіком це завжди
добре
англійський джентельман усе ще хоче бути
добре одягненим
Тож він просто розширився і вибір
фасонів і свою кольорову палітру
[музика]
питання не тільки вибору краватки
програма У фокусі Європи і телекомпанії
Deutsche Welle завершується побачимося
наступного тижня всем найкращого
українською мовою озвучено центром Меді
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесю
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юлія Лисенко та Олесь гон
Київ 2022 рік